[Music]
that's his look and that's where he's
been swearing this year Oh turn back the
puffs air to block trevor booker and
desperate to get to the basket and score
hey he that's his look and that's where
he's been scoring this year Oh turn back
the clock there to bluff trevor booker
and desperate to get to the basket and
score Hey
and here you're gonna see the nice
reaction and you know back in the day
when he was a defender let's face it he
was twelve times all defense nine times
on the first team now you like the
reaction here because he gets
double-teamed week you be and I
anxiously await to email to find out
where we're flying
Kobe number two while they're playing
some there's no doubt about it
talent he's got a lot of bounce a lot of
energy every night he gives him the
strong moves going to the basketball
[Applause]
get that jump now this is just Kobe at
his best he knew that there was a
potential shot clock watch him come
underneath so that the defender cannot
go for the block shot great move the 50
guy getting everything that's loose Kobe
Porter o for Bryant after missing his
first five greater get the company where
he shattered from he might not score 50
he might shoot 50 times 29 years old on
Saturday look at Kobe keeping the ball
feeling it fire
this is like old times our shots so far
the first night I have Toby hit five in
a row and got him going at Staples call
a favorite Shaquille O'Neal Court saw
well you know anytime he's got in the
basket tonight Mike he's he's been able
up little right by his defender
tell ya his best say Hill Hill where he
out with the ball fakes and then once he
makes his move he'll take advantage of
the rotation people if you're not there
quicken throws to tie the game and then
the Lakers gave up out Kobe came out
three years for three how does a dagger
that's the old Posey there's been nobody
liked this guy he's been able to execute
at all hall of fame level under where we
went to Germany for the blood Trent
you know the circulation of blood then
the elbow all right then the bad finger
and then the shoulder battles in anyway
six points in 53 seconds high that's
assistant Heyward standing right with
him Bryant scores anyway and he say
remember what Jack said when police
interviewed him escaping a crossover and
then came in at switched and this one
that was just couldn't get the roll on
the three but he's gonna
not a shot at to the basket Kobe they
wanted to dunk though yeah they're happy
with the eat away in your face going
away and this one I'm just going strong
for the Lakers who are lucky enough to
get some ball came out to them it's the
most open shots they'll ever have here
tonight
Kobe comes up with the steal right on
the drive to the basket hangs its go
ahead just watch he's really working
here okay now this is I'm coming down in
I still have to get by the shot clock er
played the glass gets the bash burger
journalist for nba.com Kobe baseline
Cooper Neto has 30 to move off the glass
now this is Kobe going on us right here
up in traffic out of his 1346 game so
just under a third
[Applause]
[Music]
it's all good / Ingles it'll be a three
it really was very instrumental I know
who's coming here go into the basket
37 for Brian's moving floor on right it
was nice both like Kobe down inside
where this is seeking Kobe for three yes
hey he said hey you be I heard the three
for 16 second time for the first time
since November of 2014
Kobe going out inside you the other
obviously disciple League impact B Matt
Jordan didn't do it against the goals
Brian here it's another 343 awake we
have nine players from Brazil this year
I think that would surprise a lot of
baby
45
all night long every time that he gave
he and Kobe have a very special unique
bond Bryan gets to the basket and has
got the seven points here at Staples as
Kobe comes to the line perhaps for the
last time
Seba gets 50 here Bryan got one to the
basket 50 point game in his farewell
so the Lakers are in this one down the
stretch
and there it is the first player to end
his career final minute 30 Bryant from
14
[Applause]
unbelievable stuff tonight Kobe's got
the Lakers last check
Brian for three
[Applause]
it's bit of him being left out here
tonight he scored the Lakers last 13 he
has 56 points the Lakers down was will
Kobe give them one last gamer Bryant on
the move with the jumper
58 points and the Lakers lead
he has been great and on his final night
it's one last glimpse of the greatness
a 16-point
[Applause]
sixty
[Applause]